امريكا تعلن تلقي منظومه باتريوت في
اوكرانيا ضربه روسيه واوكرانيا في
رغم تفاؤل ديمقراطي جمهوري بالتوصل لاتفاق
حول سقف الديون بايدن يقول انه ما زال
الكثير يجب عمله لحل الازمه
محادثات لاردوغان وكالجدار مع صاحب المركز
الثالث في انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه
للحصول على تاييد انصاره في الاعاده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال مسؤولون شبكه السي ان احد
انظمه للدفاع الجوي تعرض لاضرار لكن لم
يتم تدميره وذلك بعده هجوما صاروخيا روسي
قرب قال المسؤول نواش طن لا تزال تقيم حجم
الضرر الذي اصاب النظام كما نقلت سيانا عن
مسؤولين قولهم ان اوكرانيا بدات باستخدام
الصواريخ ستورم شادو المقدمه من بريطانيا
لضرب اهداف روسيه
على الجانب الاخر اكدت مصادر العربيه ان
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه نفد تعرض اي
منظومه دفاعيه لها لاي ضرر وان جميع
الصواريخ الروسيه تم اسقاطها في الهواء
قبل وصولها الى اهدافها
بعد اعلان من احد المسؤولين
الامريكيين عن
نفط وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بشكل ممتاز
عبر نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان مليار
الذي صرحت لاحدى المسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه وايضا في تدوين عبر تويتر نفت
ان تكون تعرضت اي منظومه جويه ليس فقط اي
منظومه جويه لاي اضرار خاصه ان الاهداف
التي تم اسقاطها على امراه سكان العاصمه
الاوكرانيه تم اصابتها جميعها في الهواء
ولم يكن هناك سقوط اي صاروخ على اي هدف في
محيط او في مقاطعه كييف او حتى فوق او في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
اكدت اوكرانيا انها استعادت من القوات
الروسيه 20 كيلومترا مربعا في محيط بخموت
المحاصره في شرق البلاد حيث تدور هناك
معارك شرسه بين الجانبين منذ عده اشهر
قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هنا
ماليار في بيان ان القوات الروسيه تم
ارغامها على التخلي عن اجزاء من الاراضي
المحيطه بالمدينه مشيره في الوقت نفسه لان
القوات الروسيه تتقدم داخل باخموت وتقوم
بعمليه تدمير واسعه للمدينه
في الاثناء شارت رئاسه الحكومه البريطانيه
الى ان لندن تعتزم بناء تحالف دولي
لمساعده اوكرانيا في الحصول على طائرات
مقاتله من طراز اف 16 شدد رئيس الوزراء
ريشونيك عن اهميه ان يزود الحلفاء
اوكرانيا بمساعده امنيه طويله الامد لضمان
قدرتها على رضع هجمات مستقبليه
من جانبه اكد وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
جيمس كليبرلي على ضروره ان تظل بلاده
والولايات المتحده موحدتين لمواجهه
التهديدات النوويه لروسيا
اود التاكيد على ان زيارتيون هي للحديث مع
الاداره الامريكيه وعرض وجهه نظر بريطانيا
بشان القضايا الرئيسيه بما في ذلك
التهديدات النوويه المحتمله لروسيا وايران
تم الحديث مع مشرعينا ومسؤولين امريكيين
من بينهم مايك ماكول لنقل وجهه نظر
بريطانيا للاداره الامريكيه ومجلس الشيوخ
لا تتفق الولايه المتحده والمملكه المتحده
دائما لكن يجب ان تظل متحدتين ضد الاسلحه
النوويه الروسيه والايرانيه
امام مفترق طرق حاسم في حربها ضد روسيا
والفرصه قد تكون مواتيه لكييف من اجل حسم
المعركه صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه الوقت
مناسب لاوكرانيا لتوجيه ضربه موجعه لموسكو
فما هي العوامل التي ترجح كفتكيف العامل
الاول الانقسامات بين الجنرالات الروس
العامل الثاني تغيير بوتين للقاده
العسكريين على امتداد الحرب
العامل الثالث استنزاف القوات الروسيه في
معركه ضخمه
العامل الرابع فشل حملات التجنيد الروسيه
في حسم الحرب
العامل الخامس زياده تدفق اسلحه الغرب الى
اوكرانيا
اعتبر وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لاوكرانيا والطريقه التي تقاوم فيها كياف
قوات موسكو يقدمان درسا قيمه لتايوان اذ
بين كيف يمكن لجيش اصغر فيها ان يتصدى
لجيش اكبر وخلال جلسه استماعا امام لجنه
بمجلس الشيوخ قال اوستن انه هو بفضل الدعم
الكبير الذي حصلت عليه كياف لم تمنع
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه من احتلالها فحسب
بل استعاده قسما من الاراضي التي استولت
عليها قوات موسكو في الايام الاولى للغزو
كشف الكريم ان موسكو لم تحدد موقفها الجهه
تمديد اتفاق البحر الاسود الذي يضمن تصدير
الحبوب لاوكرانيا الى مختلف اقاليم العالم
بحسب المتحدث باسم الكريم
ما زالت روسيا تملك اسئله حول هذا الاتفاق
يطرق الجوع مجددا ابواب ملايين البشر مع
تزايد مخاوف عدم تمديد اتفاق البحر الاسود
والذي يضمن تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى
العالم الاتفاق الذي يضم روسيا واوكرانيا
وتركيا وترعاه الامم المتحده تنتهي
صلاحيته في 18 من مايو في حال فشل التجديد
بالتزامن مع التلويح الروسي بتعليقه انهاء
الاتفاق يضرب اوكرانيا سله العالم
الغذائيه والتي اصلا تاثر قطاعها الزراعي
بطبيعات القصف الروسي فتراجعت محاصيلها
الى ادنى مستويات لها منذ عقد انقره
والامم المتحده فشلت بالحصول على ضمانات
تجديد الاتفاق فيما يستمر تقاذف التهم بين
موسكو وكيف حول الجهه المسؤوله عن الازمه
انه امر مثير للاشمئزاز ان تتظاهر روسيا
انها الجانب الخاسر في الاتفاق ولن اذكر
المجلس بعدم اخلاقيه مثل هذه الشكاوى من
الدوله المعتديه والتي كانت ولا تزال
التهديد الوحيد لشحنات الغذاء في البحر
الاسود
حذرنا من اننا لا نستطيع المضيف الاتفاق
ان لم تتم معالجه القضايا التي تعيق
امدادات القطاع الزراعي الروسي تسعى الامم
المتحده الى دعم روسيا لتحقيق مطالبها
وانقاذ الاتفاق فموسكو تربط المضي بالات
بازاله كل العراقيل امام صادراتها من
الحبوب والاسمده الى ذلك تطالب باستئناف
خط الانابيب الذي ينقل الامونيا الروسيه
الى موانئ اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى رفع
القيود المفروضه على المدفوعات والخدمات
اللوجستيه والتامين المرتبطه بالشحنات
فضلا عن اعاده ربط البنك الزراعي الروسي
بنظام سويفت العالمي للدفع غادرت اخر
السفن الغذائيه موانئ اوكرانيا بموجب
الاتفاق ليصل بذلك الى نهايته عمليا الا
ان محاولات احيائه تستمر لاسيما مع تضاعف
المخاوف على مستقبل القطع الزراعي
الاوكراني بسبب تاثيرات القصف والالغام
على خصوبه الاراضي الزراعيه الاوكرانيه
قرر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اختصار جوله
كان مقررا ان يقوم بها في اسيا هذا
الاسبوع اجرائي مفاوضات بالغه الاهميه مع
الجمهوريين لتفادي تخلفا كارثي محتمل عن
سداد
اجتماعا مثمرا اخر مع زعماء الكونجرس بشان
مسار العمل للتاكد من ان الولايات المتحده
لا تتخلف عن سداد ديونها لاول مره فوفقا
لوكاله مودز للتصنيف الائتماني فان
اقتصادنا سيصبح في حاله ركود وما يقرب من
ثمانيه ملايين امريكي سيفقدون وظائفهم في
حال حصول ذلك لقد اوضحت في اجتماع اليوم
ان التخلف عن السداد ليس خيارا ولا ينبغي
ان تمنع الخلافات السياسيه بين الاحزاب
الكونجرس من ايثاء الولايات المتحده
بالتزاماتها فلم يسبق لنا ان تخلفنا عن
سداد ديوننا ولن نفعل ذلك ابدا
[موسيقى]
الى البيت الابيض للتفاوض على رفع سقف
الدين العام الامريكي وبدا الحزب
الديمقراطي مصرا على لوم الجمهوريين في
تعثر الطرفين في الوصول الى الدفاع
المجموعه الوحيده في واشنطن التي تهدد
بالتخلف عن دفع الديون هي النواب
الجمهوريين اما الجمهوريون فوجهوا لومبهم
الى الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن واتهموه
بالتغيب عن المحادثات يوم ما دفع الامور
الى شفير الهاويه ان ميرين على الرئيس ان
يقدم افكارا محدده ان لم يكن مقترحنا في
الكونغرس
تبدو هذه القضيه سياسيه بامتياز
فالجمهوريون يلومون الاداره الامريكيه على
رفضها التفاوض وخفض المصروفات نتسبب بتضخم
ديون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي
تتخطى الان عتبه 31 تريليون دولار اما
الديمقراطيون فيلومون الجمهوريين بالتسبب
بازمه وربما انهيار دولار واسواق الاسهم
ومدخرات الامريكيين ومعاشاتهم وربما يكون
الامر صحيحا لو فشلت المفاوضات بين
الطرفين في اخر الشهر
اولا تخفض وكالات التصنيف ترتيب الولايات
المتحده ويتبع ذلك دفع الدوله فائده اعلى
على الديون وايضا بعض الناس لن يتسلموا
مدفوعاتهم في حينها وستكون هناك فوضى حول
افضليه وتوقيت الدفع
لكنه لا يتوقع ان تحصل كل هذه الامور دفعه
واحده بل يبقى الامريكيون على مسافه
اسبوعين من لحظه تقول فيها الخزانه
الامريكيه انها ستتوقف عن الدفع
وقد انتهى اجتماع البيت الابيض بالاتفاق
على متابعه المفاوضات
لدينا مهله 15 يوما لايجاد وسيله لخفض
الصرف ورفع مستوى الدين وتحسين الاقتصاد
وهكذا يبقى الاقتصاد الامريكي على شفير
الهاويه
وسيضطر الرئيس الامريكي لقطع جزء من رحلته
الى المحيط الهادئ للمفاوضات مع
الجمهوريين عندما يعود في الغنم العربيه
واشنطن
تتزايد المخاوف من ازمه سقف الدين
الحكوميه الامريكيه تهدد البلاد بالتخلف
عن سداد ديونها والذي سيصاحبه تدهور
اقتصادي هو الاول من نوعه في تاريخ البلاد
ما هي ازمه سقف الديون بامريكا عام 2021
تم رفع حد سقف الديون ليصل الى 31 تريليون
دولار
ماذا يعني وضع سقف للديك يجب ان لا يزيد
اجمالي قروض الحكومه الامريكيه عن هذا
الحد سقف الديون هو اجراء وضعه الكونجرس
لاول مره في عام 1917 لتمويل الحرب
العالميه الاولى
الدين العام الامريكي بلغ واحدا وثلاثين
تريليونا و700 مليار دولار ما يعادل 130%
من الناتج المحلي
الكونجرس هو من يحدد المبلغ المسموح
باستدانته للاستمرار في الانفاق على
الخدمات العموميه وفي حال فشل الكونجرس في
رفع سقف الدين ستضطر الحكومه لتحديد
اولويات الانفاق العام الحكومه لن تكون
قادره على تمويل العجز في الموازنه
الاقتصاد الامريكي سيعاني حينها من زياده
كبيره في الفائده على السندات
خسائر فادحه ستواجهها اسواق المال
الامريكيه والعالميه والاقتصاد الامريكي
سيقع في فخر الركود تاخر الولايات المتحده
عن تسديد فواترها سيؤثر على توازن الدولار
وسيفقد سته ملايين وظائفهم وايضا رفع
مستوى البطاله لنحو تسعه في المئه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
احتجاجات مقرره بالقرب من قصر مهرجان كان
تزامنا مع انطلاقه
اهلا بكم من جديد دعائي الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ناخبين الاتراك الى دعمه في
جوله الاعاده من انتخابات الرئاسه في
الثامن والعشرين من مايو جاري من اجل
الحفاظ على استقرار تركيا في الوقت الذي
يسعى فيه لتمديد حكمه الى عقد ثالث قال
اردوغان ان تركيا بحاجه الى الانسجام بين
البرلمان والرياسه من اجل حكم فعال
اضافانا الوجود القوي للتحالف الشعب في
البرلمان سيجعل حكوماته اقوى ونتناغم بين
السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه سيساعد في
تنميه البلاد
اعلن مرشح الرئاسه التركيه سنان اوغان
الذي حل ثالثا في الدوره الاولى من
الانتخابات انه منفتح على الحوار مع كلا
المرشحين للدوره الثانيه وفي مقابله مع
وكاله فرانسبريس قال اوغان الذي لا ينتمي
الى اي حزب سياسي انه سيتخذ القرار
المناسب لتوجيه ناخبيه لدعم اردوغان اوغلو
بعد محادثات سيجريها مع الطرفين وجدد
اوغان تاكيده انه يؤيد اعتماد موقف حازم
من القضيه الكرديه ويعارض الارهاب بجميع
اشكاله
فاصل بين جولتين انتخابيتين في تركيا لا
مجال فيه للاستراحه بل سيكونان الاسبوعين
الاكثر مشقه لطرفي المنافسه للوصول الى
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للفوز
[تصفيق]
نفس قومي يضع في تركيا متجليا في نتائج
الانتخابات فبالرغم من تقدم تحالف اردوغان
على المعارضه ذات الطابع القومي الا ان
المحللين ووسائل الاعلام باختلاف توجهاتها
اتفقت على ان الاحزاب القوميه حتى تلك
التي لم تكن ضمن ائتلاف المعارضه استطاعت
ان تترك بصمه واضحه في نتائج الانتخابات
ان احدى النتائج الاكثر لفتا للانتباه في
انتخابات هذا العام هي بلا شك صعود اصوات
القوميين من النتائج المهمه الاخرى
للانتخابات ثقل الناخبين القوميين في
المعادلات السياسيه
اما الخلاف في الاوساط الاعلاميه
والسياسيه في تركيا فهو حول دوري اصوات
سنان اوغان مرشح تحالف الاجداد القومي
والذي حصل على خمسه في المئه من الاصوات
وفي مصلحه اي طرف ستصب تلك الاصوات بعد
خروجه من السباق الانتخابي وان كانت ستغير
شيئا من النتيجه
وذلك للتفاوض مع المرشحين الذين تركا
للجوله الثانيه
لا ينبغي لاحد الاعتقاد بان الاصوات
المدلى بها لسنان اجان هي اصوات صلبه
تمسكين بالمحاوله الاخيره يدعو داعم
المعارضه الى جذب اصوات مرشح حزب البلد
القومي محرم انجا الذي انسحب قبل ايام من
الانتخابات بينما يرى اخرون ان نتيجه
محسومه اصلا لصالح اردوغان طاقه محرم انجي
يجب احضارها الى تحالف الامه اذا كان ذلك
ممكنا اردوغان سيذهب الى الجوله الثانيه
بثلاث مزايا على الاقل هي الاغلبيه في
البرلمان والمركز الاول في انتخابات
الرئاسه الاولى والتقدم الواضح
نقطه واحده تلعب على نتيجه الجوله القادمه
وهي اصوات القوميين المنسحبين من السباق
الانتخابي والذين لا يفضلون ايا من
المرشحين الحاليين ومن جهه اخرى محاوله
اردوغان لكسب اصوات الاكراد في اسطنبول
اذا عمر العربيه
قال الجيش السوداني في بياننا اشتباكات
جرت مع قوات الدعم السريع في شمال مدينه
بحري ووسط الخرطوم نتج عنها خسائر كبيره
في القوات والاسلحه والمركبات بيان الجيش
ذكر ان الموقف العمليات مستقر بعموم
البلاد عدد اجزاء من العاصمه بدورها قوات
الدعم السريع اتهمت الجيش بشن هجوم على
مواقعها في شمال الخرطوم بحري اوضحتا
استولت على معسكر السواق او عددا من
معسكرات الشمال البحري واعتقلت اكثر من
700 جندي بالاضافه الى مقتل العشرات
وفي السودان لفت قوات الدعم السريه تعرض
البعثات الدبلوماسيه بالخرطوم لهجمات
مؤكده انها تحت حمايته قبل ذلك قال لواء
نبيل عبد الله الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني
ان ظروف الحرب منعت قوات الامن من توفير
الحمايه اللازمه لمقر البعثات الدبلوماسيه
عبد الله اتهم قوات الدعم السريعه بمهاجمه
مقر دبلوماسيه ونهب ممتلكاتها واتلاف ما
فيها من مستندات اضاف نطق باسم الجيش
السوداني ان ادله اتهام قوات الدعم
السريعه بشن تلك الهجمات تستند الى بلاغات
تقدمت بها السفارات فضلا عن روايات شهود
عيان
كشف تقريرنا امريكي ان مرحله ما بعد
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر من حربي افغانستان
والعراق وما اطلق عليه الحرب الدوليه ضد
الارهاب اسهمت في زياده اعداد الوفيات
سواء بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
اكثر من 22 عاما مرت على هذه اللحظات
العصيبه احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
وتلتها حروب عده اودت بحياه ملايين
المدنيين والعسكريين تقرير جديد لجامعه
براون الاميركيه ونشرته واشنطن بوست قال
ان توابع هجمات سبتمبر من حربي العراق
وافغانستان اضافه لموجات الهجمات
الارهابيه اسهمت في زياده اعداد الوفيات
ومنذ عام 2010 يقوم فريق مكون من 50 باحثا
وخبيرا قانونيا اضافه الى عاملين في مجال
حقوق الانسان بمتابعه وتحليل الارقام
جامعه براون قالت ان الوفيات بفعل
النزاعات بافغانستان وباكستان والعراق
وسوريا وليبيا والصومال وعده دول اخرى
وصلت الى رقم يقارب اربعه ملايين الف شخص
وهو رقم في تزايد مستمر
وبحسب اخر تقدير لهم فان 906 الاف شخص من
بينهم
387 الف مدني ماتوا بشكل مباشر في مرحله
ما بعد هجمات سبتمبر من بين حالات الوفيات
سجل التقرير ثلاثه ملايين الف وفاء غير
مباشره نجمت عن التدهور الاقتصادي والبيئي
والنفسي والظروف الصحيه
التقرير اعتمد على الارقام فقط دون تحديد
مسؤوليه الوفيات وان كانت مقصوده خاصه مع
وجود الكثير من الاطراف المتحاربه سواء
كانت دولا ام مجموعات مسلحه حسن جوليد
العربيه
تفقد زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ اون
اول قمر صناعي للاستطلاع العسكري لبلاده
ووافق على خطط العمل المستقبليه للجنه
التحضير لاطلاق القمر ووفقا لما ذكرته
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه الرسميه
جونغ اون اكد على الطبيعه الاستراتيجيه
لامتلاكي اقمار صناعيه للاستطلاع العسكري
وقال ان لبلاده الحق في الدفاع عن النفس
ضد تصعيد واشنطن
اعلنت بكين ان سفينه الصيد الصيني يا
جناحت في المحيط الهندي مع اسفر عن فقدان
كامل لافراد طاقمها وعدد
39 شخصا على متنها قالت قناه سي سي تي في
تلفزيونيه الحكوميه انه حتى الان لم يعثر
على اي من المفقودين وهم سبعه عشر صينيا
و17 اندونيسيا وخمسه فلبينيين مشيره الى
ان الرئيس الصيني امر على الفور باطلاق
عمليه بحث وانقاذ
رحب ايلون ماسك بمديره تويتر التنفيذيه
الجديده ليندا يا كارينو خلال اجتماع شركه
تسلا السنوي في اوستن واعتبر ان المنصه
الان في مكان مستقر
اظن ان تويتر الان في مكان مستقر ومن
الواضح انني متحمس جدا لانضمام ليندا
كارينو واعتقد انها ستقوم بعمل رائع في
اداره المنصه وبالطبع ساقدم المشهوره بشان
اي تطوير تكنولوجي
ينطلق مهرجان كان هذا العام على خلفيه
اضطرابات في فرنسا اذ تقرر تنظيم عدد من
الاحتجاجات بالقرب من قصر المهرجان وسط
اجراءات امنيه مشدده مفرد العربيه الى كان
سعد المسعودي وهذا التقرير عن افتتاح
المهرجان
[موسيقى]
التي اختار المهرجان صورتها لتكون ملصقا
رسميا لهذا العام ثم تحدثت عن تضامنها مع
اوكرانيا وتحدثت ببعض كلمات اوكرانيه
افكر قبل كل شيء في اوكرانيا واتمنى كل
السعاده والحريه لهم ويبقى لدينا امل ثم
اعلنت بمعيه الممثل الامريكي عن بدء
المهرجان
[تصفيق]
العالميه على مدى ايام المهرجان وسيعرض
نحو 100 فيلم من بينها 21 فيلما في
المسابقه الرسميه متعه المشاهده لافلام
كبار صناعه سينما العالميه في مهرجان كان
والذي يستمر حتى
السابق من ماي واي الرجالي وحضور اللافت
للسينما العربيه في المسابقات الرسميه سعد
المسعود العربيه مهرجان كان السينمائي
جنوب فرنسا
في نهايه نشره تفكيرهم بابرز العناوين
امريكا تعلن تلقي منظومه باتريوتي
اوكرانيا ضربه روسيه واوكرانيا فيه
رغم تفاؤل ديمقراطي جمهوري بالتوصل لاتفاق
حول سقف الديون بايدن يقول انه ما زال
الكثير يجب عمله لحل الازمه
محادثات لاردوغان وكليجدار مع صاحب المركز
الثالث في انتخابات الرئاسات التركيه
للحصول على تاييد انصاره في جوله الاعاده
شكرا لكم على كرام المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات